[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro de mode d'emploi votre magazine
consacré à l'emploi et aux formations
focus aujourd'hui sur les métiers de
l'automobile tout de suite le sommaire
c'est le premier centre de recherche et
développement automobile en europe le
technocentre renault de guyancourt plus
de onze mille salariés travaillent sur
site
nous nous sommes glissés parmi eux pour
découvrir deux activités autour des
batteries des véhicules électriques et
des systèmes châssis un campus
spécifiques aux métiers de l'automobile
à guyancourt la première rentrée s'est
déroulée en septembre 2018
des formations à londres du ca paix au
niveau ingénieur découverte de
l'établissement dans cette édition
avant de prendre la direction du
technocentre de guyancourt
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
pour découvrir la place du secteur de
l'automobile dans l'économie
saint-quentinoise un montage signé jules
grenier ville c'est une filière
d'excellence pour l'économie de saint
quentin en yvelines le secteur de
l'automobile représente 14 mille emplois
sur l'agglomération des salariés
répartis dans 150 entreprises avec des
marques reconnues comme renault nissan
mercedes ou encore bmw mais aussi un
équipementiers comme valeo présents sur
la commune de la verrière des
différentes activités du secteur sont
représentés équipementiers un générique
constructeur distribution ou encore
location des projets innovants sont en
cours de développement sur saint quentin
en yvelines comme la voiture électrique
et le véhicule autonome la richesse de
ce secteur s'appuie aussi sur différents
établissements de formation comme
l'université versailles saint quentin
l'estaca ou encore le nouveau campus de
guyancourt dédié aux métiers de
l'automobile et de la mobilité
c'est le coeur de l'automobile sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le technocentre renault
installé à guyancourt depuis 1998 sur
150 hectares il accueille de nombreux
métiers liés à la conception des
véhicules
nous nous sommes rendus sur place avec
patrick jacques de dixmude le
technocentre renault de guyancourt plus
de onze mille collaborateurs travaillent
ici au quotidien c'est le premier centre
de recherche et développement automobile
en europe
des activités comme l'ingénierie la
mécanique
le design ou encore la définition des
produits de demain
partons tout de suite à la découverte de
ses métiers
[Musique]
ce
nous avons rejoint sylvain bonnart qui
est architecte métier batterie au
technocentre renault de guyancourt au
smarttv lab un atelier de réflexion sur
les innovations du véhicule électrique
bonjour bonjour alors nous sommes à la
direction mécanique du technocentre en
quoi consiste ce pôle alors la direction
mécanique s'occupe de développer tout ce
qui est organes mécaniques dans un
véhicule traditionnellement c'était les
moteurs thermiques et les boîtes de
vitesses maintenant aujourd'hui la
réflexion porte de plus en plus sur les
organes électrifié donc ici vous avez
exemple sur les véhicules électriques
la vraie nouveauté en plus du moteur
électrique un concombre ambiance c'est
les batteries dont je m'occupe en tant
qu'architecte synthèse métier batterie
donc grosso modo je suis en charge de
représenter ces objets est de faire en
sorte qu'ils arrivent à l'heure où vers
la direction de projets qui nous confie
ses missions concrètement vous fait quoi
au quotidien concrètement c'est beaucoup
d'interactions avec beaucoup de métier
en fait il faut arriver au jour le jour
à veiller à ce que tous les paramètres
projet que ce soit technique coût délai
ne dérive pas et convergent vers la
feuille de route qu'on nous a données
donc c'est énormément de temps
interaction avec tous les métiers avec
les fournisseurs avec les experts avec
le commerce des fois la prévente les
choses comme ça c'est très vaste
alors concrètement le véhicule
électrique c'est en voie de
développement qu'est ce que vous faites
actuellement ici au technocentre sur les
batteries du véhicule électrique
alors les batteries c'est vraiment une
nouvelle aventure dans l'automobile le
moteur électrique on pourrait dire
qu'ils aient finalement il est presque
plus vieux que le moteur thermique
les batteries au sens lithium fer
nouvelle génération à on va dire c'est
vraiment la révolution dans vos
smartphones vous en avais que depuis
quelques années dans les véhicules
électriques c'est que depuis une dizaine
d'années qu'on sait à peu près de 60
donc c'est un métier très neuf pour la
mécanique aussi c'est très neuf c'est un
mélange entre mécanique chimie et des
ordres de grandeur qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude de voir à une batterie sur
ses véhicules ça se voit pas mais elle
occupe quasiment tout le plancher du
véhicule sans injecter 300 kg
un mètre soixante delon 80 cm de large
qui donc qu'il ya des interactions très
forte avec le véhicule mais qui doit en
même temps répondre à tous les cahiers
des charges demandées en prestation sur
la vitesse l'autonomie le temps de
recharge etc
beaucoup de champ des possibles on va
dire et une convergence technique pas du
tout murs qui fait que au jour le jour
on se pose des questions on est toujours
amené à développer ou inventer encore
encore maintenant le champ des possibles
assez ouvert qui dit champ des possibles
ou verdi source d'emploi je suppose
oui tout à fait tout à fait en ce moment
c'est les métiers nouveaux cd profil qui
sont peu répandus dans l'industrie
surtout automobile donc ça nous amène à
aller chercher des profils d'emplois
dans d'autres métiers on a beaucoup de
chimistes qui sont arrivés dans la
direction de la mécanique ce qui était
nouveau mais on a besoin de conversion
on a besoin de gens finalement à
l'esprit très ouvert qui savent aller
chercher des idées dans d'autres
secteurs on s'est beaucoup inspiré
d'autres secteurs finalement puisque
historique ne l'avions pas et en effet
c'est les métiers de demain pour moi il
n'y a aucun doute là dessus
[Musique]
après avoir découvert les métiers autour
de la batterie des véhicules électriques
direction maintenant le paul châssis
pour découvrir les métiers autour des
pneumatiques des roues et des
enjoliveurs en compagnie de sarah bois
là mais les pilotes fonctions système
châssis bonjour bonjour alors en quoi ce
consiste ce poste donc aujourd'hui
j'interviens sur le développement des
systèmes embarqués du contrôle châssis
est en fait ça consiste à assurer une
certaine stabilité véhicules en gérant
ou en commandant les différents systèmes
châssis à savoir est le système de
direction
les systèmes de suspension etc c'est un
métier qui se trouve au coeur
développement du véhicule du futur
notamment le véhicule électrique et le
véhicule autonome vous venez de le dire
c'était véhicule du futur forcément ces
sources d'employabilité effectivement
parce qu'aujourd'hui la stratégie
renault s'est engagé ou de recruter des
jeunes qui ont cette avidité de
développer le véhicule du futur et donc
enfin aujourd'hui dans l'équipe contrôle
châssis donc on cherche notamment des
profits des profils orientés automatique
mécanique du véhicule et parce que
renault a confiance en la jeunesse
donc bien sûr pas enchanté profil qui
deux rives qui sont intéressés par ces
métiers là donc la désinformation autour
de la mécanique de la conception
mécanique de tout ce qui est contre au
châssis des lois de commandes est
automatique
voilà merci beaucoup merci à vous
après la conception et la fabrication
vient la vente et la maintenance des
véhicules découverte du métier de
mécanicien dans une concession
rencontre avec sylvain chambaz je
m'appelle cinéma chambaz j'ai 35 ans je
travaille chez bmw pajon depuis 19 ans
j'ai eu la chance d'être d'être pris en
stage d'une semaine pendant
pendant la classe de troisième donc
grâce à cette semaine étant donné que
j'étais très motivé donc le chef
d'atelier de l'époque m'a fait confiance
pour mon apprentissage donc deux ans de
bep deux ans de bac pro après donc j'ai
été embauché et vu que je voulais
évoluer
j'ai fait ma demande adem w france pour
faire la formation technicien service
est maintenant surtout chez bmw où ils
sont très haut nil innovateur et du coup
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'électronique
donc il faut vraiment se mettre à la
page et une évolution permanente
on sait en branches à la voiture sur la
prise de diagnostic la prise au bd pour
pouvoir communiquer avec avec
l'ordinateur
donc là il fait le test de tous les
boîtiers électroniques présents dans le
véhicule
et si vous souhaitez devenir mécanicien
vous trouverez une formation au campus
des services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité à guyancourt
ce nouvel établissement vient d'ouvrir
ses portes en septembre 2018
il propose des cursus allant du cp au
niveau ingénieur plusieurs activités du
secteur de l'automobile
reportage il a ouvert ses portes en
septembre 2018 le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité
installé sur cinq hectares à guyancourt
pour sa première rentrée il a accueilli
plus de 500 personnes réparties en
quatre centres de formation liên cm
consacré au cycle et au motocycles et
trois autres établissements dédiés aux
métiers de l'automobile le gnf à la fort
pas et le gard ac et je vous propose de
découvrir la formation au maintenance
des véhicules à travers un cours de
mécanique
[Musique]
ces apprentis que vous voyez à l'image
sont en seconde en bac pro maintenance
des véhicules leur programme de la
matinée le réglage des moteurs essence
et le changement de la courroie de
distribution
[Musique]
au cube aulas ici on va contrôler le
réglage des culbuteurs on m'a déjà
positionné ses culbutes en avant la
bonne question est ce que je peux bouger
les culbuteurs non qu'est ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure à partir de là que ce que
je faisais qu'on utilise jeu de calais
dès qu'elles contiennent des vins une
cale des carottes la note qu'elle ne pas
c'est pour cela que je suis au rectum en
impeccable donc du coup bah ça veut dire
que le réglage été correct et nous nous
retrouvons ici dans un atelier du centre
de formation d'apprentis de la fort pas
et derrière nous des élèves à pied
d'oeuvre en cours de mécanique en
compagnie d'hélène levasseur responsable
du centre de formation bonjour bonjour
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter la fort pas donc là fort pas
est un organisme de formation destinée
aux jeunes qui souhaitent débuter une
formation professionnelle en alternance
nous proposons des formations pour le
véhicule léger pour le véhicule
industriel pour le dépannage du ca paix
en passant par le bac pro le bts et des
contrats de professionnalisation quels
sont les cours enseignés alors des cours
de matières générales des cours de
matières professionnelles pas mal
d'ateliers 8 heures 7 à 8 heures en fait
par semaine à qui sont destinés ces
différentes formations
la plupart des jeunes en fait qui
s'adressent à nous ensuite aux 15 ans 16
ans donc ce sont des sorties de
troisième
bien évidemment des jeunes un petit peu
plus âgés jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans quel
est l'intérêt de former en alternance
c'est à dire que ces élèves en fait sont
en entreprise et en même temps ils sont
en formation ici comment ça se passe
tout à fait donc ils sont une semaine
sur deux au cfa en entreprise
leur formation se déroule donc sur une
année voire faim voire trois années pour
le bac pro
l'intérêt de cette formation est une
formation purement professionnel destiné
à les insérer beaucoup plus rapidement
sur le marché du travail puisque en
entreprise
ils y font à la fois leurs armes et ont
un débouché quasiment immédiat alors
justement quels métiers peuvent exercer
après ces différentes formations
un jeune ans et appellent va devenir
forcément donc mécanicien simples
véhicules légers véhicules industriels
s'il souhaite forcément développé un
petit peu ses compétences il va
poursuivre vers un bac vers un bts vers
éventuellement des contrats de
professionnalisation un petit peu plus
liée à la haute technicité
[Musique]
et
pour sa première rentrée scolaire à
guyancourt lafore pas forme 196
apprentis l'établissement espère
accueillir 300 jeunes à partir de 2021
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis si vous souhaitez
revoir cette émission rendez vous sur le
site internet ou sur notre application
mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]